hey guys it's Justine and today we've
got a mystery box of some Star Wars
gaming goodies I'm so excited about this
razor said they had a little surprise to
send me and that it was Star Wars
related and I would love it so naturally
I said yes please send and I can't wait
to see what it is so let's unbox what
have we got in here new all so wait you
guys might know I've been doing some
decorating some painting a little office
remodel
I painted like everything black my
entire place I paid it all the walls
super dark as you can tell it's now dark
mode Justine and a lot of you guys have
been saying but this stuff is gonna look
so prepared a movie oh wow I've been so
obsessed with this mouse pad I've got
the one in the courts pink color and I
was just thinking okay my new office is
completely dark and black and a desk is
black too i'll great it would be to have
a black one of these I honestly just
office today but this is a stormtrooper
version I've just kind of crouched down
to get into this shot look at this we've
got some other things take a freaking
look at it it's a stormtrooper mouse if
this isn't something that is gonna get
you hyped up then I don't know what is I
went to the Star Wars Celebration in
Chicago it was like the best time ever
you see it I can't breathe online I can
breathe but if it's struggling a little
bit where do I even start
this is the Black Widow light and I love
this because it's a smaller version than
some of their bigger keyboards I'm
having a moment it's been a while since
I've been like super excited about
something
who love Star Wars I love Star Wars so
much it's so crazy because I never saw
Star Wars until I was an adult so I kind
of have this weird kind of relationship
with it because a lot of people grew up
with it I did not I never saw it until I
was older now as an adult I'm always
this is beautiful
this is absolutely incredible honestly
tell me something that you've seen that
is better I love it so much I love that
was having these little cord wraps
because I'm disgusting when it comes to
core advantage of it next up the Star
Wars stormtrooper extended mousepad shut
it's absolutely incredible oh don't
worry we have a mouse to go with it
don't think I forgot we need the mouse
to complete the set it's beautiful it is
absolutely stunning difference with
batteries
you're just a waffle and if you take a
look at this open your eyes if you just
blink you need to stop blinking and just
force your eyes open go like this and
put them up to your screen right now do
that take a picture of yourself looking
at this mouse and tweet it to me guys
hurt okay don't do that it's a bad idea
this is gonna match the decor in that
office so perfectly because the walls
are completely black but the ceiling is
still white and the trim and the doors
are white so basically I already have a
stormtrooper office and this just takes
it to a whole nother level which one is
your favorite is it the extended
mousepad the keyboard or the
stormtrooper Mouse and kind of really
into the mouse it looks so good well see
you guys in my next video I look forward
to showing you this new office redo it's
been something that I've been working on
way too long I've been setting so much
time redoing offices and moving
furniture around I'm not actually
accomplishing anything
I'm just shifting things from place to
place but hopefully soon I'll have her
settle it and I can show it to you guys
but in the meantime make sure you guys
are subscribed to my channel and also be
sure to hit the bell because that's how
you guys will be notified when I post
new videos because I'm not really sure
of subscriptions work the way that they
should let the notification Bell we'll
make sure that you guys are alerted so I
will see you guys in my next video and
may the force be with you
oh also so this is a complete side note
but I wanted to show you guys this
because I only posted this stuff on
Instagram when I went to the Star Wars
Celebration I went out there with Lego
and it was so cool they had this
incredible display a little tiny mini
figures that made up a massive
stormtrooper helmet
let me show you guys this quick little
clip that I filmed on my insta 360 1x
camera which is a really cool 360 camera
that is one of my favorites a lot of you
guys on Twitter were asking me how I was
able to get this shot without having the
stick in the shot so it kind of looked
like I had a floating drone following me
but it was the insta 360 1x
okay now this is really the end of the
video I promise bye
[Music]
[Applause]